notre enquête a commencé ici à
Brazaville au Congo le premier médecin
nous ouvrir les portes de son service et
le
professeur en moyenne sur les 120 lit de
son service une vingtaine sont occupé en
permanence par des malades du sida qu'il
ne pourra pas
soigner 15 à 20 par semaine là
aujourd'hui par exemple j'eni 1 2 3 4 5
6 7 8 9 10 11 12 1 14 rien de commun
dans cet hôpital avec les moyens dont on
dispose à Paris par exemple pour traiter
les malades du sida l'hôpital manque de
tout de seringue de médicaments on dit
même que le coû annuel de traitement
d'un cas de sida à San Francisco est à
de chos près le budget annuel d'un
hôpital africain tout à fait on a mieux
que ça pour ces médecins qui chaque jour
doivent faire face à cette épidémie avec
si peu de moyens il est difficile de
résister au
désespoir de nombreuses évaluations
considèrent que dans les 5 années à
venir plusieurs centaines de milliers de
personnes mourront du sida comme ces
malades que nous avons rencontrés mais
le vrai problème auquel la plupart des
pays d'Afrique sont confrontés déjà
aujourd'hui c'est la population de
céropositif pour le docteur crzy
biologiste et spécialiste du sida
tropical qui nous a accompagné tout au
long de cette mission c'est la première
conclusion importante c'est très
préoccupant ça n'a aucune commun de
mesure avec ce qu'on peut connaître nous
en en
Europe les taux de séropositivité qu'on
a rencontré dans les pays nous sommes
allés allait de 7 à 30 % de la
population générale ce qui qui sont des
chiffres énorme quel est à titre
indicatif le taux de céropositivité dans
la population française par exemple en
France les taux de céropositivité vont
de 0 002 à 004
% ces taux de séropositivité surprenant
dest en ouest de l'Afrique pourrait bien
dans les prochaines années mettre en
péril l'équilibre démographique de tout
un continent d'autant que les
populations risque sont en train de
changer des nouvelles populations à
risque c'est pas vraiment ce qu'on peut
dire en fait c'est des gens qui sont
particulièrement exposés de par leur
façon de vivre mais c'est toujours des
gens des hétérosexuels en particulier
donc on a vu les prostitué qui
représentent une population exposée
extraordinaire parce que nous avons
rencontré un taux de copositivité qui
allait de 25 à 0
dans certains cas on a vu en anda une
étude qui avait montré que chez les
camionneurs il y
avaitent deitivé
33%me sans être inutilement alarmiste on
peut reconnaître que l'Afrique entière
est sous la menace du sida et que plus
que jamais nous devons être solid pour
faire face à cette
épidémie